hi this is pressure Locker in this video
we're going to end the debate on a
problem that commonly circulates around
the internet and usually generates a lot
of discussion
the problem is six minus one times zero
plus two divided by two some people say
the answer is seven and other people
strongly disagree and say the answer is
one so what's the answer this question
has some importance because in Canada
you actually have to solve this kind of
math problem to claim lottery or contest
prizes so let's try and figure it out
when we type the expression into Wolfram
Alpha we get the result of seven
similarly when we type it into Google it
also evaluates to the answer of seven
the disagreement comes because if you
type the same expression into an
old-school calculator it will evaluate
the result as being equal to one so
what's the correct answer well clearly
there's a potential for confusion and to
avoid that we need to come up with a
convention of how to evaluate these
expressions so there's only one answer
the acronym PEMDAS or bed moss is one
way to remember how we evaluate
expressions so we look at the things
that are in parentheses or brackets
first then exponents then we look at
multiplication and division and finally
addition and subtraction and otherwise
we go from left to right so for our
problem there is a multiplication one
times zero which needs to take
precedence that evaluates as 0 then
there's a division of 2 divided by 2
that needs to evaluate that evaluates
into 1 and finally we go left to right
so 6 minus 0 plus 1 is equal to 7 so the
correct answer to this expression is 7
and that's what we got in Wolfram Alpha
and Google and that's they got the
correct answer because they do
followed the order of operations on old
calculators it will just evaluate it
from left to right and that could end up
with the wrong answer so you always want
to be careful and followed the order of
operations I hope you like this video
please subscribe to my channel you can
support me on patreon catch me on my
blog mind your decisions on Twitter at
pressure Locker and you can get my books
listed on my website